Fondamentalement, c'est notre travail de dire à ces enfants que ce monde vaut la peine d'être vécu.
J'en suis venu à penser que je dois être au cœur de mon travail.
ça n'a toujours pas changé
[musique]
ouvrir
rare
L'oeuvre de Miyazaki
Puisqu'il est fait avec son individualité, la personne qui hérite de cette individualité est cette personne.
Je ne l'ai pas, alors peut-être que l'iPhone fabriqué par Miyazakiya est celui-ci
Je ne pense pas qu'il y ait un avenir
[musique]
Ouais ouais ouais
concernant
dents
de
libéré
Comment était-ce en 2 minutes? Type intégré
denham
libéré
Je suis ce dauphin.
Je voudrais exprimer mes sincères regrets d'avoir pu faire face aux dégâts en toute sécurité en le réglant.
Je suis une personne qui pense que je dois
Eroparo
dee dee
Bonjour le monde
00 minutes 00
Il semble que c'était à Tomomachi pendant un certain temps.
re n
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
merci
[musique]
nous sommes le roi star 2 à faire si vous le
mation et tourner l'histoire lou reed
[applaudissements]
[musique]
moi
J'ai
non
t4
moi
Oh oh oh
aucun
non
Je ne l'ai pas créé avec l'intention de créer quelque chose de japonais.
L'avez-vous fait parce que vous vouliez le montrer aux enfants autour de vous ?
Mais est-ce que ces Américains vont battre Barber, qui dit ne pas comprendre Kaonashi ?
Quand j'y pense, quand n'est-il pas venu ?
Il y a tellement de gens qui sont liés par le dos, à la fois les créateurs et les téléspectateurs.
Je pense qu'il y en a beaucoup au Japon aussi.
[musique]
Ouais
non
[applaudissements]
[musique]
Pas
moi
Ouais ouais ouais
[musique]
Je pense que ce serait douloureux s'il y avait le sentiment que j'avais coupé les coins ronds, mais de toute façon
Comme si j'avais atteint le point où je peux atteindre
j'ai toujours pensé
Après que ce soit fini, il n'y avait plus rien
Je sais que ce n'est pas bon, mais être guéri tout d'un coup n'existe absolument pas.
Je suis allé dans un magasin où je ne voulais pas me retourner
[musique]
Il a fallu 5 ans à Po-sama pour former une équipe murée.
en attendant bien sur
Ce n'est pas que j'ai continué à faire des films, mais j'ai écrit des scénarios et des choses comme ça.
Je fais beaucoup de choses différentes, comme rentrer chez moi ou faire des courts métrages dans des musées.
ça prend cinq ans
Si vous commencez à penser à ce prochain travail maintenant, peut-être
Oh cher
j'ai cet âge
Bouh Bouh
Je suis une personne qui a fait du bruit en disant que j'abandonnais le thème plusieurs fois.
Je pense quand même le remettre.
c'est ça
Ce temps
Je suis sérieux
avait
[musique]
J'abandonne le papier et le crayon
Ce magasin est uniquement avec le film Arakura.
c'était le bon moment
[musique]
vaudou
érotiquefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe
détails
[musique]
de
rejeter
A cette époque, beaucoup de clients sont entrés et m'ont fait rire.
Notre souhait est ceci
C'est un film que j'ai fait, je veux le montrer à mes enfants quand ils seront parents.
Je pense qu'il s'agit de faire des films comme
[musique]
Ouais